Doctor Trebuchet sighed, his breath fogging
up the visor of his hazmat suit.
He did a last-minute spot check, making sure
he had his clipboard and pen.
Then, he reached for the shoe box, feeling
its little occupant moving around as he lifted
it up.
The doctor turned as his newly appointed assistant,
Researcher Wachtel, barrelled into the room.
The researcher was late; Trebuchet couldn’t
imagine ever being tardy to his first assignment.
But the Foundation were insistent on training
up their new recruits as quickly as possible.
Exposure to a mostly harmless anomaly would,
in theory, help to normalize some of the stranger
SCPs that the organization dealt with.
Doctor Trebuchet held back a cheap shot about
Wachtel being so late, as the Assistant Researcher
hurriedly clambered into his own hazmat suit.
Both ready, they stepped through the decontamination
airlock after it had hissed loudly, sterilizing
the air and the outer layers of their suits.
Then, the two researchers continued into the
containment unit.
Even with their hazmat suits on, the differences
in temperature and humidity were instantly
noticeable, like the feeling you get stepping
off a plane after a long-haul flight.
The cylindrical glass enclosure had been perfectly
climate controlled, filled with wetland soil
and stagnant water.
It was like stepping inside a terrarium, a
tiny little pocket of swamp large enough for
someone…
well, something to comfortably live inside.
That something was SCP-811, sometimes known
colloquially by her nickname of the Swamp
Woman.
However, since bringing her into containment,
SCP-811 had given herself a different name,
which Doctor Trebuchet used when addressing
the slimy creature.
“Aé,” he greeted, causing SCP-811 to
turn and face the pair of Foundation personnel.
“Dockty, what want?”
she hissed – she had shown the capacity
for communication, but possessed a limited
vocabulary and struggled with the proper pronunciation
of words.
Doctor Trebuchet clarified he was there to
ask SCP-811 questions, to which she quickly
responded with a request for food.
Opening up the shoebox, a frog hopped out,
which the Swamp Woman quickly stomped on and
began to eat the dead creature.
Although, while she possessed a mouth, she
didn’t exactly ‘eat’ in the sense that
we understand it.
Her body secrets a slimy mucus that, upon
contact, causes a rapid rate of decomposition.
Much like a fly, SCP-811 will vomit onto things
in order to break them down so she can digest
their nutrients through absorption.
She uses this ability both to hunt, and as
a defensive countermeasure against attackers,
spitting out the waste of her food that collects
in her stomach.
Grinning at her own efforts, SCP-811 finished
her meal and indicated she was ready to continue
with questioning.
Doctor Trebuchet handed his clipboard to Researcher
Wachtel so that he could conduct the interview
as part of his on-the-job training.
“What is the earliest thing you can remember?”
Wachtel asked, reading from the board.
“Air-wee is thing?”
SCP-811 echoed; conveying that she didn’t
fully understand.
Wachtel stammered, unsure how to rephrase.
“Early things,” Doctor Trebuchet interjected.
“Things…
before.”
“Before box?”
Aé seemed to be understanding, indicating
her containment chamber.
“Before before box,” Trebuchet confirmed.
Appearing thoughtful for a moment, SCP-811
asked: “Most before?”
Doctor Trebuchet nodded vigorously, telling
her ‘Yes’; even though the Foundation
had mandated this interview, he genuinely
wanted to know how she had become like this.
Immediately, SCP-811 gave sweeping, demonstrative
gestures with her hands and described – in
very vague levels of detail – a man.
A man who had been taller than Aé herself,
at a time when she was also much, much smaller.
“Was like man,” she said, pointing at
her own arm.
“What was like him?”
Doctor Trebuchet probed, trying to clarify
what she meant.
In response, Aé pinched her mottled green
skin, its surface slick with mucus.
“This!
Not like Aé.
Like man.
Like people!”
she insisted.
Her skin, she had meant her skin had used
to look human.
Upon hearing the word‘ skin’ from the
doctor, SCP-811 repeated it, prodding at her
arm, and then smiled; she’d learned a new
word.
When questioned further by Doctor Trebuchet
– while Wachtel felt increasingly uneasy
nearby – the Swamp Woman pointed to the
inside of her elbow.
She described what she had experienced after
this tall man had approached her:
“Pain stick here.
Cold,” Aé said.
“Needle, Aé,” Doctor Trebuchet encouraged
her to use the right word, certain she meant
she had been injected with something.
“They’re called needles.”
“Knee-doll here,” SCP-811 tried to mimic
the sounds of the word, before then going
on to explain that she had experienced intense
pain soon after.
With her hands, she started miming that something
had come out of her mouth.
“Red.
Red, red, red.
Was… very hunger-y.
Ate man.
Skin… like this.”
Hearing her describe, even in loose, broken
terminology, what had happened to her, became
too much for Assistant Researcher Wachtel.
As far as both he and Doctor Trebuchet understood
what Aé was telling them, she had been injected
with something while still a child, and then
had… eaten the person responsible.
Wachtel, who had children of his own, couldn’t
help but imagine the same horrible act happening
to his own kids; and the thought of it made
him vomit in his hazmat suit.
Given her own chosen method of attacking and
dissolving prey, SCP-811 couldn’t help that
she interpreted seeing Wachtel throwing up
as an act of hostility.
It alarmed the Swamp Woman, causing her to
hurriedly retreat to a nearby pool of stagnant
water within her containment chamber, refusing
to remerge until Wachtel and Doctor Trebuchet
had left.
Angered by the Assistant Researcher’s lack
of professionalism and how it had interrupted
the most coherent explanation of SCP-811’s
past, Doctor trebuchet filed a dissatisfied
note with the SCP Foundation.
It read:
“While I understand the appeal of training
the new blood on something relatively harmless
and as green as they are, could you please
throw them at some other humanoid for a while?
I'm trying to actually get things done here.”
Had Wachtel been able to stomach what he had
heard SCP-811 saying, and probably through
more extensive interviews with the creature,
Trebuchet could have learned the full extent
of how the Swamp Woman had come to be.
She had been able to give the broad strokes
of it, of course, but her descriptive ability
was limited.
The story had definitely fit with what the
Foundation already assumed to be the case;
that, at some point, Aé had been human.
But what they hadn’t been aware of was the
actions of this unknown individual – a nameless
man – or what he had injected the young
girl with in order to trigger her transformation.
At any rate, the only explanation the Foundation
had was the word of SCP-811 herself.
It was vague at best; at worst it might not
have even been recalled with any degree of
accuracy.
She could have been lying, if she even had
the capacity to lie.
And the specifics of who she was before, why
someone had injected her and what with, were
all still a complete mystery to the Foundation.
And not just to them either.
Given her partial comprehension, SCP-811 had
long been suspected to have grown up as a
feral child, a youngster abandoned when they
were only a few years of age, rather than
as an infant.
It certainly seemed to explain her limited
understanding of human language; the fact
she could communicate at all implied she had,
at some point, lived among other humans, but
hadn’t fully developed before her transformation.
But even if she had been able to communicate
at an adult level, SCP-811 still wouldn’t
have given the full story to Doctor Trebuchet.
Not because she was keeping things from him,
but because she simply couldn’t.
The trauma of growing up alone in the swamp,
being turned into a monster, and everything
else that had come before, were all too much
for her.
She had, at some point, suffered a mental
break, her mind shutting off the full details
of her past as a defense mechanism.
The Swamp Woman had been through far more
– and far worse – than even she could
remember.
And, unbeknownst to the girl who would later
come to call herself Aé, the SCP Foundation
had been involved…
It had all started way back, a long time ago,
and many, many miles away from where it would
eventually lead to the birth of the Swamp
Woman.
Specifically, it began in Siberia.
The SCP Foundation had learned of an infectious
skin disease that had been discovered there
by GRU Division P, the Russian government’s
own anomaly containment organization.
They had encountered a virus that was highly
contagious, and that would spread on direct
contact with organic matter.
But that was far from the extent of it.
This infection would begin to transform its
host, turning them into a horrific fleshy
mutation that would attack any non-infected
life form in an aggressive attempt to spread
the virus further.
The Foundation called it SCP-610, although
the GRU P troops had a different name for
it: roughly translated, they called it ‘The
Flesh That Hates’.
Now, it was only through a combined effort
between the SCP Foundation and their Russian
counterparts in GRU Division P that this disease
was contained to a single, isolated area within
Siberia where it had first been discovered.
The Russian government at the time had agreed
to keep the area under their watchful eye,
and that anyone who became infected by SCP-610
would be killed immediately.
Of course, nobody had accounted for the one
who would get away.
A Russian operative, a researcher within GRU
P, had become obsessed with SCP-610 since
its discovery.
The virus itself was horrific, producing abominable
nightmares, but it could transform human physiology
in mere moments, producing fleshy creatures
that were almost unrecognizable as people.
This scientist began to wonder, if this transformative
property of the virus could somehow be controlled,
programmed even, then it may well hold the
key to some of the greatest breakthroughs
in medical science.
He envisioned using it to grow replacement
limbs out of tissue cells, or to trigger the
reconstructive regeneration of bodily damage.
The scientist just needed to figure out how
to prevent SCP-610 from fully transforming
someone; the only problem was anyone infected
with it was killed.
So, he took it upon himself to sneak into
the isolated area in Siberia, where he could
steal a sample of SCP-610 from the body of
a recently terminated mutation.
And he nearly made it away unscathed…
The scientist’s plans were quickly discovered
by the joint effort between the SCP Foundation
and GRU P. He had been requesting a sample
through the official channels for months,
and now he had taken one to experiment with
and gone on the run with a new identity.
Calling himself ‘Alec Holland’, the scientist
fled the Foundation-Russian agents sent to
pursue him.
As far as he knew, they were trying to prevent
him from carrying out what he viewed to be
a noble endeavor.
But the Foundation knew that, if even that
tiny sample of SCP-610 was able to spread,
it could cause a worldwide catastrophe.
Whilst piloting a small plane, Alec was shot
down over the swamplands of Louisiana.
By the time Foundation operatives arrived
in the area, all they found was a burning
wreck.
Little did they realize, Alec had been rescued
by locals, who had taken him aboard their
fan boat and rushed him to hospital.
He would later leave, before his injuries
had fully healed, and returned to the site
of the crash to discover something curious.
His sample of SCP-610 had been cross-contaminated
with the swamp’s stagnant water, teeming
with algae and who knows what else.
Alec was running out of time.
He knew that, if his wounds didn’t kill
him, he would soon be discovered by the Foundation
and GRU P. Using a syringe, he gathered up
the combination of the virus sample that had
mixed with the natural properties of the swamp.
There was no way of knowing what it would
do, whether it would still mutate a person,
or whether the disease’s transformative
effect had been altered.
But he had to know, and he was living on borrowed
time.
Desperate, he raced to the nearest town, a
tiny community near the swamp.
The first person, Alec told himself, the first
person he encountered would be his test subject.
He had to see what effect this altered version
of the virus would do to a human being.
It just so happened that the first person
he encountered was a little girl named Aé.
And he wouldn’t live long enough to see
the full extent of what he was about to turn
her into…
Now go check out “SCP-173 ORIGIN STORY - HOW
173 GOT TO SITE-19” and “SCP-053 YOUNG
GIRL” for more mysterious anomalies!